regardez ce qui assure le site d'apple
ce matin salut c'est monsieur on est
aujourd'hui le lundi 16 juillet 2018
lendemain de la victoire de l'équipe de
france en coupe du monde 2e étoile
même apple 6 mai pour les féliciter et
félicitations à toute l'équipe de france
tous les supporters
alors au delà de l'aspect un peu
footballistique j'espère vraiment que
cette victoire va paraître un petit peu
de resserrer les liens et il ajoute un
peu de fraternité dans tout le bordel
voilà ça c'est dit aujourd'hui on va
parler d'apple d'apple pourquoi parce
que d'ici un mois et demi à peu près un
mois et demi à deux mois
on va dire un mois et demi va arriver là
clignote du mois de septembre une pin up
qui va vraiment être orientés matériel
au mois de juin la dame a eu la bonne
idée s'ils étaient exclusivement
logiciel là on va avoir une pinotte
exclusivement matériels avec plein de
nouveaux produits à se mettre sous la
dent donc sans en parler il ya des infos
intéressantes et rumeurs plutôt bien
renseigné qui circulent et on va en
parler aussi
l'info ne nous vient pas de n'importe où
l'info nous vient de mines tico tico
vous connaissez probablement son nom
était chez kg sécurities et a priori il
a changé de maison il est maintenant je
sais pf international sécurities et
michiko continue à nous régaler avec ses
prédictions ses analyses il a quand même
été hyper pertinent avec beaucoup de
malice car il parle pas c'est ce qui
fait de lui l'analyste numéro un en ce
qui concerne apple
qu'est-ce que mythique où nous annoncent
ils nous annoncent plusieurs mises à
jour de produits
on a déjà parlé des iphone il va y avoir
un iphone 6,5 pouces avec un écran oled
un iphone 5 2 8 pouces avec un écran
oled un iphone 6,1 pouces un peu moins
cher
low cost toujours chez apple on était
grande mais avec un écran lcd devraient
arriver également cette année une
nouvelle apple watch nouvel ipad prod et
mac revue et visitée
on en est déjà un qui sortirait pas
longtemps c'est le macbook pro de 2018
il devrait avoir également d'autres
produits le design de la paix watch
d'agde 2015 c'est vrai qu'elle a quand
même un côté un peu old school avec ses
grandes bordures et doit y avoir une
mise à jour se produit on garderait
toujours un modèle 39 mm et un modèle 42
mm mais l'écran grandir et on pas vrai
donc ses grands bordure noire pour avoir
un écran quasiment bord à bord un écran
qui passeraient sur le modèle en 39 mm
de 1,32 à 1,5 pouce et charles modèle à
42 mm de 1,57 à 1,60 18 pouces un écran
un peu plus grand mais surtout la grande
nouveauté ce qui serait intéressant
c'est vraiment d'avoir un écran qui la
dre lécher le mort dont une montre
beaucoup plus contemporaine les écrans
ben amor cartonne en 2018 ça serait
quand même bien qu'apple médecins
montrent au goût du jour
à noter que micro prévoit un capteur de
rythme cardiaque améliorer ça c'est
plutôt bien pour les sportifs il devrait
y avoir du nouveau de la gamme macbook
apple annoncé le 12
il y est donc il ya de ça quelques jours
un nouveau macbook pro 2018
j'en ai déjà parlé dans une précédente
vidéo mais à priori il pourrait y avoir
un nouveau macbook
longtemps pressenti comme étant un
macbook air se serait finalement un
macbook parce qu'apple devrait laisser
tomber la gamme macbook air on aurait
donc un macbook d'entrée de gamme qui
coûterait entre 799 à 899 dollars si
vous voulez le plan euro vous faites la
conversion il vous rajouter 20 % de pda
et voudriez la voir il devrait aussi y
avoir une mise à jour du mac mini est
plutôt pressenti comme partant aux
oubliettes
a priori dure une mise à jour matérielle
un mac mini qui serait donc un peu plus
boosté et il devrait y avoir mise à jour
de la gamme mac et notamment
significatif au niveau de l'affichage
mézague pas ne serait pas en reste apple
a déjà sorti cette année un ipad 9,7
pouces d'entrée de gamme moins cher
destiné aux étudiants et au grand public
là on va arriver serein n'est pas
destiné aux professionnels il devrait
donc y avoir une mise à jour de l'ipad
12 9 pouces qui inclurait veille saïdi
et forcément la disparition du bouton
home
à noter que cet ipad 2 12 heures 8 9
pouces il devrait y avoir une réduction
du châssis on va forcément toujours la
même taille de l'écran puisque je vous
parle de 12,9 tous mais par contre le
chah 6e derrière et lui on devrait
néanmoins garder des bords soient cotées
qui permettrait d'intégrer frey saïdi et
l'ipad de 2.5 pouces disparaîtrait et
arrivera un nouvel ipad 2 11 pouces avec
également un châssis un peu plus réduite
permettrait d'augmenter le ratio taille
de l'écran châssis air power ferait
enfin son arrivée après son annonce
l'année dernière par d'un petit peut
arriver celui-là il serait bon aussi une
petite mise à jour du côté des herbes
folles avec notamment la fonctionnalité
des scieries qui voit l'arrivée et
toutes les infos nous vient du site
night ou fnac.com
dites moi ce que vous en pensez vous
qu'est ce que vous attendez d'apple au
mois de septembre
qu'est ce que vous voudriez qu'ils
arrivent comme mise à jour qu'est-ce qui
vous surprendre et au delà des iphone on
parle beaucoup des iphone parce que
c'est vraiment le produit phare le
produit le plus grand public d'apple
il ya plein de produits il ya plein de
choses au catalogue une dites moi vous
ce qui pourrait vous intéresser au delà
des prédictions 2006 qu au delà de ce
qui est un petit peu perçu comme mise à
jour dites moi vous personnellement ce
qui vous ferait plaisir qu'elle produit
nour et vous faire craquer et comment
est ce que vous le verriez vous marquez
tout ça en commentaire comme d'habitude
je vous remercie d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo véritable essai des jolies pousse
à vous abonner parce qu'on parlait
toujours plus de tête
de toute façon ces infos dès qu'elles
vont sortir avec laura latine
apple on va être présent dessus
directement pour tout suivre et en
parler donc restez connectés d'ici là
soyez sages portez vous bien si vous
êtes en vacances
excellence vacances et encore
félicitations bleus tout
[Musique]